what has taken place over the last week
as there's been disturbances and riots
by mostly by israeli arabs from the
cities in the north of israel all the
way down to the south of israel
with the uh incidents that have taken
place including attacking police
officers burning police vehicles
attacking innocent israelis and
civilians and that is something that
we cannot accept and therefore strategic
move has been made by the israeli
national police in order to make sure
that we have enough police units to
respond
to those types of incidents and contain
the violence as much as possible
considering what we've seen over the
last week
yeah but you know we can't pretend that
this was not violence
both ways there were attacks on arab
israelis there were attacks on
arab-israeli property you can't
pretend that this violence was one way
can you first of all nobody is
pretending but if we look at the number
of incidents that have taken place
our police units and officers and their
vehicles were were not burnt
by uh jewish people who took to the
streets what did take place and that's
correct is there a number of uh
different groups that took to the
streets in retaliation
we contained and prevented incidents
from taking place and deteriorating
and our main emphasis at the moment is
number one working tactically on the
ground to make sure that there is less
violence on the streets
every night as we've seen there's a full
scale curfew in the city of lod
which will continue as long as necessary
i'm also calling to the leaders of the
different
israeli arab communities to prevent
violence from taking place and we're
calling upon the mayors of the cities to
be involved
in those efforts as well
yeah but mr rosenthal i've got to put it
to you that several arab israelis have
been speaking to our correspondents and
they say
that they have no faith in the israeli
police to protect
them they say that jewish gangs have
been roaming
almost with impunity what would you say
about those accusations
first of all the uh situation between
the israeli national police and the
israel and the israeli arab community we
have a strong bond
and there are hundreds of police
officers who serve in the israeli
national police until now until the
outbreak of violence
the situation the uh the relationship
was a good strong relationship it's very
sad to see that unfortunately israeli
arabs have taken to the streets of
course jewish people want to protect
themselves because
unfortunately we can't be at every place
and every area
and that is something that people were
very very worried about but there's a
number of ongoing investigations taking
place both within the israeli-arab
community as well as in the jewish
community
to find those suspects who were involved
in the incidents but
but unfortunately and that is something
we have to confirm but all
right but also mr roosevelt also mr but
also mr rosenfeld we have seen
jewish gangs attacking um arab israelis
we have
seen the police out shooting at vehicles
with without the drivers in the shooting
through vehicles smashing the windows
of vehicles belonging to um arab
israelis in some circumstances
i mean they're saying that they simply
do not trust
the police and they're saying that
actually one told us the other day that
the police were was becoming a sort of
security arm
of right-wing groups that's absolutely
incorrect the israeli national police
respond to every incident that takes
place
both within the israeli arab community
as well as within the jewish communities
our main efforts are to prevent
incidents from taking place
unfortunately over the last two weeks of
ramadan here in jerusalem
we saw thousands of israeli arabs taking
to the streets
targeting innocent people in the streets
in a democratic country that is
something that is totally unacceptable
and therefore we had to respond our
units are deployed all across the
country we've seen over the last
24 hours the situation is improving and
once again the message to the
communities
is don't be involved in violence our
police units are ready to respond if
necessary
and we're hoping that things will
gradually calm down i also want to
emphasize that the israeli national
police are also at the same time
working down south all the way across
ashkelon ashdod and the other cities
which are being
stricken by those rocks from the hamas
and our units and our bomb disposal
experts are responding
all the time can you guarantee to arab
israelis that you
are their police force as well
absolutely and if the israeli arab
community don't take to the streets and
are not involved in violence
we will be there to support them we will
be there in order to make sure that we
build up the connection once again but
at this moment because the tensions are
still high
we're messaging out both to the israeli
arab public as well as to the jewish
public
do not stir up incidents do not take to
the streets let's calm the situation
down
let's work together let's emphasize what
it's all about
taking a step ahead and bridging the
gaps as quick as possible